if you love movies history and
dams you're in luck you can now catch
highlights of boulder city's damn short
film festival online now last year the
pandemic forced the festival to go
virtual its executive director says that
actually opened the idea of making this
virtual part of it permanent so now the
festival is going to have this virtual
component moving forward in a showcase
of the top short films
it's something that we can really
have pride in the great talent that is
in nevada and it really gets
lets us get to know
a lot about our state because
a lot of these films are about nevada
and people in nevada and and issues that
we face
which we love the movies are streaming
online through the end of the month
tickets to watch them online are 10 they
can be bought on the festival's website
meanwhile the in-person 18th annual damn
short film festival starts today down in
boulder city last through sunday our
bigger apartments in february lasts
through the 14th of february at the
historic boulder theater